هل تريد أن تأتي في مغامرة
معي ، أنت قادم
[موسيقى] لقد
مشيت عبر النهر الجليدي لقد تسلقت
الجبل الجليدي على الشاطئ الشمالي هنا
تجدفت إلى جزيرة مهجورة
وأمضيت اليوم في قراءة الرسائل هناك
[موسيقى]
i  عملت في شركة مناسبة لعائلتي
والتي
توقفت تمامًا خلال
جميع هذه المطاعم ، حيث
تم إغلاق كل شيء غير أساسي إلى حد كبير
هنا ،
لكننا ما زلنا قادرين على الاستمتاع بالطبيعة
التي كانت لدينا هنا في
كل مكان هنا في
فانكوفر ذهبت إلى المدرسة من أجل  التنقيب عن المعادن
وكنت
أفعل ذلك لبضع سنوات
وكان ذلك مثل التعرض لطائرات الهليكوبتر
والتعرض لمثل المشي على الأنهار
الجليدية ومثل الخروج لساعات في كل
مرة بمفردك ،
لا أعتقد أن الحياة تتحسن من هذا
[موسيقى
] تأثر الكثير من المدن الأصلية للأشخاص أو
المناطق المحيطة بها
بشكل سلبي جدًا بسبب هذا وأعتقد أنه إذا
كنت قادرًا على البقاء قريبًا في البداية في
رحلتك الأولى ،
مثل إظهار القليل من الامتنان
لرحلتك الأولى  لا يفكر الناس في المنطقة المحيطة على أنها
نزهة ومغامرة لأنها تبدو
وكأنها لم تستغرق سوى 15 دقيقة للوصول إلى هناك ،
فأنا أحب ذلك ، ولكن ليس هذا هو الشيء الأكثر
روعة الذي يمكن أن يعيشه هذا
بيننا
وأن تكون جزءًا من
حياتنا ، فقد أتى الكثير من تقديري من
الاستمتاع الفعلي
بكل ما أوصلك إلى تلك
النقطة
حتى أشياء مثل الأرض التي
تمشي
عليها وأن هذه الغابة القديمة
وأنني تعلم أنها  سأكون هنا
لفترة أطول بكثير مما
سأكون عليه على هذه الأرض
[موسيقى]
الناس لم يستقبلوا سائحين لمدة عامين تقريبًا ،
أود أن أقول التحلي بالصبر الشديد مع
الناس واحترامهم جدًا
لذلك سأذهب في رحلة إلى  نيبال
ومؤخراً سيواجهون عددًا كبيرًا
من الحالات
ولن تحدث رحلتي إذا كانت
ستؤثر عليهم
سلبًا مثل إدراك ما
هي إرشاداتهم الصحية في ذلك الوقت هو
ما يجب أن يكون أولويتك الأولى
قبل السفر  في أي
مكان أقدره حقًا  أنك سمحت لي أن
أخرجك إلى البرية مثل هذا
شكرًا لمجيئك